the annual state of AI report is one of
the most cited documents in the field of
artificial intelligence endorsed by the
likes of Andre karpathy led by Nathan
benich this year the original co-author
Ian Hogarth is now one of the key
players at The Bletchley Global AI
Summit in November yes I read all 163
pages of this year's Edition and thought
that giving you just the highlights
interspersed with developments from just
the last few days like Eureka would a
good way of keeping you guys up to speed
but let's start out with a modality that
the report didn't cover notice on page
seven we have text image video music
robot States and we'll cover all of
those but what we don't have is thoughts
and why am I bringing that up you might
ask well because a few days ago we had
this from meta towards a realtime
decoding of images from brain activity
now I have showcased thought to image
and thought to text before on the
channel but never real time thought to
image it's not perfect but progress is
astonishing and I think it points to the
explosion of modalities that we are
seeing at the moment in AI now if you're
willing to sacrifice a realtime flow of
images from the brain this is the
state-of-the-art using fmri much more
accurate but not real time now many of
you might wonder if it works if someone
imagines an image and apparently it
doesn't work nearly as well and also at
the moment it tends not to work if the
participants are distracted by other
things as the paper says in other words
the subject's consent is not only a
legal but also a technical requirement
for brain decoding back to the report
and many pages are dedicated to covering
gp4 but to be honest anyone who's
followed this channel for any length of
time will know a fair bit more than what
is covered in these few slides so I'm
going to skip to page 14 where I have a
slight difference with one of the
conclusions they cite a paper which
describes the false promise of imitating
proprietary llms large language models
basically saying that you can imitate
the style but not the content of a
smarter model but I wish that they had
cited Orca which despite being more than
10 times smaller than the original chat
PT reaches according to the technical
paper parity with chat GPT on various
benchmarks showing only a four-point gap
in professional and academic
examinations like the SAT LSAT gr and
GMAT that's maybe why the information
reported on Microsoft trying to
substitute for gp4 with orer claiming to
mimic the quality of openai software at
a fraction of the cost on page 38 of the
report they describe open-ended learning
with large language models describing
how they can explore and gain skills in
a game like Minecraft and they say that
the best example of this kind of
self-improvement and iterative prompting
is Voyager which is again gp4 getting
better and better at Minecraft but just
after the report came out we got Eureka
and yes it deserves its own video but as
Jim fan one of the key authors said it's
like Voyager in the space of physics
simulations and essentially what they
did was feed the source code of the
environment to gp4 and then they asked
it to write the code for the reward
function and then using the sheer power
of parallelization inside nvidia's Isaac
gym they could then test out those
reward functions see which ones in
simulation work the best thanks to GPU
acceleration you could speed up reality
1,000x each time the best grading
systems would be used refined upon and
then tested again all in simulation
ultimately Eureka rewards outperformed
expert human written reward functions on
83% of the tasks performed the average
margin was 52% and Eureka was able to
learn even pen spinning tricks which are
notoriously difficult even for CGI
artists this Mar caring up of large
language models and iterative feedback
from the environment is probably the
future of AI as shatal Sha from
Microsoft said the proverbial positive
feedback loop of self-improvement might
be just around the corner that allows us
to go beyond human training data and
capabilities and to those wondering yes
they are planning to connect it to a
real robotic hand soon I was lucky
enough to get early access to the report
and one of the most convincing and
amusing demonstrations was your Eureka
learning how to run efficiently back to
the report though and if Eureka was all
about simulated embodiment getting
better with language feedback how about
language tasks being improved with
robotics data as this page demonstrates
the positive transfer seems to go both
ways gaining Vision data and embodiment
or robotics data seems to make a model
like palm e better at pure language
tasks and while the report went on to
mention rt2 watches of my channel will
know about RT 2x that showed how data
from a multiplicity of different robotic
setups could complement each other and
improve the base model the basic message
across the board is the same more data
from more modalities improving
performance across the board and so when
we get Eureka improving via feedback
from gp4 it reminds me of a previous
video where I talked about Dar 3
improving from feedback from GPT 4
Vision the same themes are reoccurring
improvements in one modality ricocheting
across two others and remember the
original palm language model and GPT 4
weren't even designed for this I am
genuinely curious about the kind of
recursive Improvement that might occur
with a model designed to be multimodal
from the Star like Gemini speaking of
Robotics though the report did mention
something I missed on the channel that's
the first time win for a robot in a
competitive sport which was firstperson
view drone racing here is a glimpse of
why these Swift system beat all the
human Champions the trajectories flown
by the humans and Swift we noticed that
the autonomous system is more consistent
across laps and is able to take tighter
turns this gives it a decisive advantage
in a
race Swift won multiple races against
each of the human Champions and achieved
the fastest recorded race
time that was
it this marks the first time that an
autonomous mobile robot has achieved a
world champion level performance in a
real world competitive sport what might
come next well these have received
approval in China for fully autonomous
flights of an electric air taxi let me
know in the comments if you would fly in
one of these eang drones at the moment
I'm undecided probably not right now I'd
have to see an action for a bit longer
on page 58 the authors describe another
year of progress in music generation but
rather than just describe this progress
I want you to hear it I'm not sponsored
by them but I've been honestly very
impressed byso AI check out a snippet of
the following rap all generated by ai ai
explain breaking through the mold diving
deep discovering Secrets
unold smarter than human it's a whole
new game unleashing Power of
technological flame if you like that one
I'm going to end the video with another
sample very quickly though the way to
test it out is to join their Discord
click on one of the chirp beaters and
then just type for/ CHP and then press
enter Then you have to press enter again
for some reason and up this will come at
the top you can put things like wrap or
classical whatever you want and then you
can either enter 4 to8 lines of your own
lyrics or have chat gbt do it for you
honestly don't make more than around
eight lines because it degrades
performance quite a lot page 63 briefly
describes the progress in medical
performance of language models and I do
honestly think that was worth
highlighting I just wonder if medp Palm
2 when it got 85% used a smart GPT like
framework because if it didn't things
like self-consistency Chain of Thought
prompting and reflection could boost the
score even higher than 85% in other
words it is not out of the question that
we could soon have in our pockets a
model capable of outperforming all but
the very best doctors at Medical
question answering speaking of medicine
apparently it's the fastest growing
field in terms of mentions of AI within
papers and just look at the breadth of
fields now applying AI to achieve
research breakthroughs and the increase
in volume and notice at the bottom how
much mathematics is benefiting from this
progress and I bet many of you don't
know about the automated Prov and proof
assistant gpf one of the co-authors of
that in 2020 was Ilia SSA of open AI it
was about proving mathematical theorems
using a GPT model and again something
many might not know is that that was
superseded in 2022 by meta their neural
theorem prover solved 10 International
math Olympiad problems that's five times
more than any previous system their
method was called hypertree proof search
and is way too complicated for me to
cover in this video and that's not even
touching Alpha tenser from Google Deep
Mind which improved upon decades old
methods for matrix multiplication that
has direct ramifications for the usage
of gpus in modern-day AI very quickly
what they did to automate algorithmic
Discovery was convert the finding of
efficient algorithms for matrix
multiplication into a single player game
and I love this bit they say this game
is incredibly challenging the number of
possible algorithms to consider is much
greater than the number of atoms in the
universe and compared to the game of Go
which remained a challenge for AI for
decades ades the number of possible
moves at each step of our game is 30
orders of magnitude larger and it's
these synergies that I'm interested in
the breakthroughs in one field will then
be applied to another the
state-of-the-art results in one modality
that push forward another modality and
the number of people trying to do this
is multiplying as well honestly I hadn't
even heard of INB apparently they have
10,000 h100s which are the most
cuttingedge gpus I don't know how I
missed an AI company with five figure
numbers of h100 gpus but here's the CEO
describing their approach at INB we're
training large Foundation models
optimized for reasoning on top of those
models we build agents that we use to
accelerate our own research and these do
more than just output something they
also iterate and reflect and figure out
what's the next step to do and then take
that next step we're starting with
agents that code because it requires
complex reasoning to be able to code
well and because that's the work we do
every day they seem to be flying
completely under the the radar with only
about 300 subscribers on their channel
so to be honest if we see the kind of
manual dexterity that Eureka promises
and a breakthrough in reasoning like INB
and frankly everyone else is working on
and if AI can start to crack
International math Olympiad problems and
compose rat battles it does start to
become a genuine question of what can't
they do I'm not saying that's true now
far from it but in the not too distant
future that may well be a very valid
question in the industry section on page
82 the authors describe the chip export
bands that apply to h100s basically
companies like Nvidia and Intel can't
sell their Cutting Edge chips to China
and select other countries and those
companies got around it by creating
models like the a100 which were just
outside of the export restriction range
well the report is already somewhat out
of date in that respect Just 4 days ago
we hear that those chips are now also
under export restrictions another
development that's occurred since the
publication of the report concerns
copyright the report detailed how
Microsoft has moved to reassure the
users of its tools that the corporation
will assume any legal risks in the event
of any copyright claims and of course
every day we seem to be reading reports
of one company or another getting sued
as it relates to AI data but just a few
days ago we had this Google giving the
same kind of indemnification basically
if the use of one of its gen AI products
triggers any copyright claims it Google
will assume legal responsibility it says
my only prediction is that this battle
over data and copyright is not going
anywhere in somewhat Grimmer news we had
a series of slides on the use of AI in
Warfare and how in real time conflicts
are being used as a lab to design the
latest and most effective weapons what
came out since the report though is news
about the potential first use of an
autonomous killer drone that's a drone
drone that can identify and attack
targets without any human control with a
human not even in the loop there were
rumors of this occurring in Libya a few
years ago but this seems to be more
confirmed apparently it's only used
autonomously when radio interference or
jamming prevents direct operator control
the article in forb says going forward
if the system is deemed to be
sufficiently reliable large numbers of
autonomous attack drones could be
deployed simultaneously without the need
for trained operators dozens of bomber
drones could attack simultaneously
immune to jamming and anti-drone guns
and while many campaigners have sought
to ban this kind of autonomous killer
robot there is still no International
agreement on doing so the pace of
Technology far outstrips the pace of
diplomacy we saw earlier in the video
that AI is better at maneuvering drones
but apparently is also better at
spotting targets and other companies say
that they are ready with an autonomous
version of their switchblade kamakazi
drone if there's a demand for it there
were quite a few pages on safety but I
worry that the debate is slipping into
two camps one that thinks we're all
doomed and the other that thinks safety
is a complete myth sadly I could see the
debate staying that way until there's an
actual incident either with autonomous
drones or a bioweapon on a lighter note
the report described the progress in
text video but again rather than reading
it out I thought I'd show you and in
this video notice that you can pause at
any moment and not discern anything
other than a beautiful landscape now to
end with here is the predictions page of
the report that it includes every year
and honestly I feel that the predictions
are a little bit too conservative their
first prediction is that a Hollywood
gray production makes use of generative
AI for visual effects but we literally
had reports of that occurring 3 days
before the report was even released it
looks like the background to this Loki
promotional image was AI generated the
clock face and so far I don't think
Disney have denied that and what about
about the third one self-improving AI
agents crush the state-of-the-art in a
complex environment they talk about
games tool use and science but to be
honest Eureka is kind of already a
demonstration of that you could call
physics simulation science or
potentially tool use so I would say this
prediction will definitely happen if not
has already happened and the fifth one
about a group spending a billion to
train a single large scale model well
multiple CEOs have already said that
that's their plan and I know it seems
like I'm being harsh but the seventh one
we see limited progress on global AI
governance Beyond high level voluntary
commitments that's a very subjective
prediction depending on the definition
of the word limited I for one do think
and predict that there will be some sort
of audit agency set up before the end of
2024 now if I'm criticizing them it
would be remiss of me not to end the
video with my own prediction I predict
that a model will be released in the
next year that will break
state-of-the-art benchmarks across at
least four different modalities
simultaneously anyway you can let me
know what you think of that prediction
and the video as a whole in the comments
thank you so much for watching as always
and as a tiny reward of watching all the
way to the end here is another rap about
this
channel' I got to say by a YouTube
channel AI explain today smarter than
humans that's what they claim diving
deep in Tech they ain't playing no games
AI explain breaking BS with might
unraveling Secrets shining knowledge so
bright they bring it down making complex
things clear teaching us all evolving
year after year